you
ah hello and welcome to another tea
session this is not going to be all that
long but I wanted to get a video in and
for about half an hour has to be enough
because I need to leave in roughly 30
minutes but let's get this that gets
this in so um starting with the three
plus two and I get one playing end game
magic okay let's play Knight a3 g3 let's
um start of the game that I've played
really a lot over the years ended
Kendra's opposed to all kinds of lines
this time we have transposed to a
Catalan
Catalan of course
before book Jaya here I go a four
you
young so it's Espen see
anytime's
yeah nightsticks looks normal here
to prepare the north eform
occupying the center miss White's
general idea in this line oh yeah I
wondered about the smooth
yeah I was thinking that night if five
could be good for a small advantage I
don't quite remember if I have featured
this in the book and it looks like it
could be because blacks on sequence iam
looks completely normal okay
interesting
move at all
[Music]
you
yeah I don't know it's probably just
equal if I take of it
didn't see anything substantially better
I expect him to play rugby eight
and now I have some interesting ideas I
can take
plain ig6 it's more of a short move
doesn't really do all that much
you
[Music]
how can i Oh some problems here
you
if I take if for I mean the e4 pawn is a
bit loose
but I don't see how
could be able to put some pressure on it
just don't see how
you
I don't know preparing Bishop before him
he just goes back
it's probably
decision yeah I don't know I kind of
miss played this
now having absolutely nothing
not sure what I did wrong
I should always have a little something
in this position and this is not
anything this isn't anything at all
don't exactly expect him to take but you
can make this pre move
you
preparing before
you
for the minority attack it's it's not
dangerous property a deck but this is
some about the only plan that I have
here
yes I thought about wasn't sure and I
think I'm going to take this
I wanted to play d5 but now I recognize
that after c5 this is probably not so
good
remembered I can go a five and maybe put
some pressure on the porn if he goes f5
this is also bid weakening
you
and it's nothing special
at all
about some way to
continued to fight at all okay this I
don't know I hear this is helping me
okay now I can take a form or let's say
I can cover this for the moment and then
I get the time to get to Bishop to c4 he
can try something like a g5 but I think
this is more weakening blacker than
anything else
show
one next and then this is a target
you
and I can never move the bishop here
against d6 check
I think I'm slowly getting somewhere
now I have the check this
to play no matter what
simply to to open up the position
the ship d6
I should be excellent for me
now the light squares are opened and I'm
threatening Bishop to d5
yeah
yeah Bishop d5 is still new here
yeah so I got there slowly with the
step-by-step I've got something which um
he still played quite well I think
just a bad concept
you
yeah this line I recommend for white and
my dear for who but I had six Bishop g5
not a four
black is quite reasonably placed in this
variation with them early queenside
expansion
I'm not quite sure how to play I rarely
played this with black
Knight quite often goes to a six in this
position
ready to take on c5 this can be relevant
in a line like this Bishop e7 if white
takes I want to take with the pawn hey I
want to take with the bishop sorry look
with the point of this day so let's take
here before you play C form
young Queen b6 and
we need to be seven is probably a good
idea
p7 is often it would scream for the
Queen and
such a scenario this is a weird move
what is that doing
hmm
looks pretty misplaced the bishop
yeah queen b7 is is on as well
yeah the thing is here I've got this
move I don't think he appreciated that
g-seven king evade and I'm threatening
Knight f4 herewith made into
that is the thing
you
yeah I'm just winning material here
right that made threat is a bit too much
I had to do something
very modest after 95 I'll show what it
see for yes so I'm just taking the night
you
yeah just a piece form
thing
you
okay there are two games
games enough I cannot even shed yeah
wanted to say thank you I have to
activate it actually
can I don't mind a rematch but I don't
want to play the same person the whole
time in one session
okay now ves
we go let's go for us the same
you
you
sometimes take on f6 I immediately
so we get the sharper line the varnish
variation
okay this is a mistake because I can
take now on d5 and then he gets a pawn
on d5 which is of course very
undesirable and in fact I can
immediately open up the position here if
he takes I go efore and whites position
is already falling apart what is he
doing here
Castle are what is best I have to
remember this
you
you
I was before a bit too quick I was just
like what is he doing him
you
yeah and I'm getting huge compensation
I'm just wondering if I have to just
wrong
maybe I just played this too quickly
think it did
and get did
it's a bit sad
yeah because I mean this is nice
but it's not I'm not winning and this is
what should have happened more or less
okay I asked to move the king now
this is also why I think
probably have some good compensation
Ruki AIDS you might have f6
hmm
you
yeah I should I should be quicker here
simply
move
threat against b-24 he's just playing
far too quickly in this this is just a
super critical position and while it's
just like yeah whatever okay so I can
take b2
and Bishop takes or queen takes
you know ahead stick with the Queen I
don't have much time left
the increment is always helping a little
bit in those situations that you
sure that you're not losing
yeah this is obviously not
wanted
okay
you
you
you
his pieces are still very loose yeah and
to lose in fact I completely I just when
it was too quickly f5 is of course
correct and if I was also correct so
yeah I actually did it right I wasn't I
wasn't really sure I castles
there should be four and then wookie
ADIS is good queenie queenie five is
also strong so I did I played it right
yeah whatever just wasn't sure if I have
anything better I just felt like mmm
shouldn't I have more but this is in
fact almost winning four black already
rookie aid is a bit stronger even yeah I
wasn't I couldn't quite figure this out
but Queen b6 is just a fantastic
positioner now also this move is strong
how does he play against us I'm
threatening also Queen d4 check
Alex Black has a fantastic initiative
here why it has to take on his seven and
disposition it's more or less the only
move okay now going back for another
game
mmm a one I can also do this once in a
while
MMA 101 or five
okay yeah yeah I have c3 in my book
I got I can also play
therefore the opens of sign
you
yeah Black has good chances to equalize
in this variation but white also has a
fairly easy game
we have a good Bishop on g2 no
weaknesses and we can develop easily
now I think
it's place he for I want
knight on c3 this looks a bit more
active
then placing it on d2
okay interesting a six
yeah he might have some Bishop e5 or c5
lined up
it would
like to know what to do against it
against Bishop b5 I think I have the
Bishop f4 this is an interesting idea
Bishop c5 I'm not sure about
to someone
you
and yes so you should see five is kind
of irritating
singing too long it's where it's very
early in the morning and sometimes just
like yeah not really fully awake yet
okay now maybe it couldn't be six
could be a little something
still having a bit of pressure on the
queenside the bishop on g2 is a good
piece
see five also
staying actually
t5 Bishop e5 should a form
maybe yeah okay this is a playable
position for sure
I'm think I'm threatening Rupert e6 now
Rock t6 quindi 626 rook takes Bishop f4
nice
okay it still works
you
and in fact here quint eggs as Bishop c5
it's even even better
just a piece up or nothing
okay
oh crap
you
I don't mind to trade
so really continuing this it's a bit of
a slight waste of time
no it's not very likely that a blunder
here um
yeah so and just take b8 xb6
I can move the book away what they
is strapped
you
yeah okay I would have liked to get in
Gaiman instead of playing this but this
is what it is
I mean you always
[Music]
to continue I'm absolutely not one of
those people saying okay em you should
have resigned or this is disrespectful
or anything like that just like if I
have a video where no I'm not really
having that much time I'd like to just
get something more interesting in the
video than this
yeah okay
okay yeah of course I'm happy to do a
rematch that wasn't really a game that
he just wants to
if they're on its own with no way of
maybe setting things setting things
straight
so another Suresh knockoff
and go this is always enjoyable
I think f there should be seven and up
in the book in the course
yeah it's often just a transposition
okay let's go at five
yeah this is a very much possible
variation after Bishop g5
has to decide who can go wish of f2
[Music]
I play this I think we have six
Queen f6 mmm yeah yeah this this would
have prevented reform
and then queen h6 where that was a bit
stupid I forgot my own
I wanted it as a stem
I add u6 what a stupid move okay
not
to
to
[Music]
the meant assault all too long
played the best possible way that the
position still remains interesting
stopping b5 for the moment
a c5 for the moment
yeah this is the thing not really that
grade
yeah and you don't want to play Bishop
yourself really don't
yeah now I've really miss played this
awfully
you
yeah not very good
yeah I think I mean I'm not really
threatening to take on b5 but if I was
white I would still retreat the night
just not giving me yeah this is
interesting
an interesting move
not sure if it threatens much
yeah
you
[Music]
you
you
I don't don't quite see anything
anything constructive that I can do
something like eform and f4 key four
takes F form Bishop f6 disarmed counter
play ideas but they don't quite work yet
okay
now Bishop f6 can be played
retina form
you
yeah he's not
maybe he is threatening to take on a six
and
and place e5 that could be possible I
now he's got c5 anyway I because of my
unprotected bishop oh wow I'm not really
doing this this too well
ow ouch
should be seven hours cooldown yeah
ahead eforea maybe I should have taken
this opportunity not that it was
fantastic but it was at least a glimmer
of counterclaim
he wants to
yeah anyway let's play
you
maybe ahead before I take you form
six is hanging always
[Music]
should have thought about this
now I'm doing this absolutely
way I'm not
even though he can play Bishop before I
am a sure
[Music]
yeah it still not exactly a good
position
oh man
night
I am
what about taking on f3 Knight f8 and
then take on e - is that possible
yeah I think I'm going to is a bit of a
gamble yeah he doesn't really try to
find out
you
now
yeah not
[Music]
it's still totally awful
you
it's okay
I'm not seeing yet how I'm losing this
by a concrete means let's a still
hanging on
tweenage forms my idea
yeah maybe it's not
totally terrible
something's going on now the night is
hanging and the pawn is hanging
hi
taking age - is not
not directly deadly let's say
but I'm threatening Queen age one
you
it's not not comfortable for white it's
also Bishop b5 check move first think
later something like that let's do this
check
maybe the check wasn't all that good
yeah
it wasn't all that good
shoot
you
yeah it actually covered it's covered on
f1 okay so guys 30 minutes is all that I
can do today but I wanted to get a video
in come on
he's rematching me like continuously how
can I stop that okay guys thanks for
watching I'll be back tomorrow with some
young problem solving video trying to
figure out complicated positions looking
forward to that getting a new book today
with positions to solve alright till
tomorrow bye bye guys
you